Trascrizione: Alessia Giorgiutti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
"C'è un tempo per nascere,
c'è un tempo per morire.
C'è un tempo per amare,
c'è un tempo per tirare sassi.
C'è un tempo per arrabbiarsi,
e un tempo per riconciliarsi.
Un tempo per fare l'amore,
e un tempo per separarsi".
Queste parole sono state cantate
molto tempo fa, circa 2500 anni fa,
con una cetra che si accordava
con i "Sette cordi":
così veniva chiamata la cetra di Qoelet.
E ognuna di queste corde,
corde di minugia,
avrebbe dovuto accordarsi
con gli astri e con i pianeti,
perché il tempo che noi viviamo
è un tempo interno
che si immilla nell'umano
e diventa ovviamente il tempo del cosmo.
Qoelet, la sapienza.
Ed è sempre stato un grande problema,
quello di poterlo definire [il tempo]:
l'uomo l'ha sempre inseguito,
l'ha sempre ricercato,
l'ha sempre ovviato.
Io oggi sono un poco qui
come il Bianconiglio di Alice, no?
Un orologio in tasca
che, in qualche maniera,
segna il mio e il nostro tempo.
Il tempo è un ritmo:
lo abbiamo appreso quando,
ancora nell'acqua delle origini,
nel grembo di nostra madre
sentivamo il battito,
il battito del suo cuore,
il battito del nostro cuore.
E gli Antichi, i Latini,
hanno quasi inventato tutto loro:
spugna di quella che è stata
la grande civiltà del Mediterraneo,
ma ovviamente un ambiente
estremamente poroso,
di molte sollecitazioni,
l'hanno trasformato
nel ritmo dell'esametro.
L'esametro era il modo
per riuscire a cantare questo battito:
è il verso dell'epica.
Ma sotto il verso dell'epica,
nelle straordinarie curve
delle carte e dei manoscritti,
si nasconde proprio questa musica
che è antica, che è antichissima,
e la sentite.
È dentro di voi, in questo momento;
il cuore può battere
più forte, meno forte,
ma è sempre quella:
ta-tattata-ta-ta-tattata-ta-ta,
"Quadrupedante putrem
sonitu quatit ungula campum".
E che cos'è?
È il tempo di una cavalcata:
una cavalcata folle, spaventosa,
una straordinaria avanzata di cavalieri
che lungo la piana di Troia
si spostano in velocità
gridando e facendo battere
il suono di quattro zoccoli
sopra un territorio putrido -
detto così in italiano è orribile,
ma il "Quadrupedante putre
sonitu quatit ungula campum"
aumenta ancora di più il ritmo,
e il ritmo si fa frenesia
e la frenesia si fa canto d'amore.
Nella notte forse più bella
della letteratura latina,
la notte raccontata da Ovidio nei Tristia,
Ovidio deve partire, deve andarsene via
per volere di un imperatore
che gli contesta il fatto
che lui abbia visto qualcosa
che non doveva vedere.
In questa ultima notte,
passata tra le braccia
della donna che ama,
e qual tempo è meglio speso,
Ovidio, sciogliendosi nei capelli di lei,
canta il battito del tempo che passa,
e ogni grano di polvere
che scende lento nella clessidra
diventa un sussurro d'amore cantato.
Ma per l'eternità, perché diventa eterno:
"Lente, lente currite noctis eques!",
"Correte piano, ma piano,
cavalli della notte!"
Perché se la notte passa troppo veloce,
se l'albeggiare arriva troppo presto,
io devo sussurrarti, mio dolce amore,
l'addio della mia esistenza;
e questo non arrivi mai.
Piede e mano battuta,
s'inganna la morte nella danza:
è il tamburello, il cembalo
che gli sciamani pulsano
ripetendo il suono antico dell'esametro.
Se fate attenzione,
se fossimo in un tempo straniato,
se fossimo in un altro luogo,
ma poco lontano da qui,
nelle colline della Morena Friulana,
e fossimo intorno al 1568 - 1570,
un musico negromante e mago
che noi ben conosciamo,
ed è Mainerio,
il grande Maestro di cappella
dei Patriarchi di Aquileia,
che qui aleggiano ancora
in un tempo sospeso,
quasi lo avvertiamo.
Inseguendo la zampogna, la cornamusa,
con piede pulsato,
con battito di piede pulsato,
andavano alla ricerca
di quella sistole e diastole,
di quel pendolo che fa incantare la luna
e che, come facevano
le streghe slovene della stessa epoca,
poteva in qualche modo fermarsi
lungo la strana corona
dei monti o delle colline
e bloccarsi lì per un momento.
Incantare significa
"cantare dentro" il senso delle cose
e bloccare -
per un attimo soltanto,
che però può durare quanto un'eternità -
il fluire del senso del tempo,
o per lo meno della sua memoria:
ferma il tempo e inganni la Morte,
che ovviamente nella danza attende invano.
È tutto lì.
È il tempo dell'essere.
È il sottile equilibrio che passa
tra Eros, l'amore,
l'energheia, l'energia -
abbiamo sentito parlare prima
di Tempo e di Cosmo -
e Thanatos, la morte.
Nei "Libri delle Ore" del Medioevo
la Morte appare con una sottile
corona d'argento;
e ricorda, non per fare paura,
che lei si presenterà
alla fine della nostra esistenza;
ma non per punirci!
Si presenterà per chiederci
se il nostro tempo
è stato un tempo ben speso;
se il tempo che abbiamo
dedicato alla nostra vita
è stato un tempo pieno di cose,
di incontri, un distillato di ebbrezza.
Questo ci chiederà quell'Oscura Signora.
Ed è tutto lì,
nella magnificenza di uno spazio
che diventa anche tempo -
vedete come il linguaggio
della fisica teorica
si abbraccia così da vicino
con il linguaggio dell'arte, della poesia,
dell'antropologia e della filosofia.
È quello spazio, quel tempo
invischiato in un dito che crea
e in un dito che viene creato.
In un senso di humanitas,
che ha a che vedere con humus
ma anche con "mano":
il nostro pollice opponibile
è quello che ci fa percepire,
forse per la prima volta,
nell'essere creatori, o sub-creatori,
nel modellare le forme e i significati,
che noi possiamo avere
il nostro tempo tra le mani.
È in quella scintilla lì di Michelangelo,
in quell'Adamo che, addormentato, sogna,
e sogna perché ancora non vive,
e non vive ancora
perché non ha il senso del tempo,
che è tutto racchiuso invece
nel Mistero dell'Inizio.
Prima di Adamo, chi c'è?
Dopo Adamo, chi ci sarà?
Adamo: l'uomo che dà i nomi alle cose,
che ruba l'anima al mondo
e che si fa lui stesso
granello di tempo e granello di polvere,
nel senso delle cose.
E questa è forse la mia preferita:
è la mia preferita perché in questo bacio,
che viene esemplato
in uno stile meraviglioso,
la pittura vascolare greca
della prima polis -
siamo nell'VIII secolo a.C. -
In questo vaso c'è un bacio
che dura da più di duemila anni,
e dura da più di 2000 anni - 2800 anni -
perché non è mai stato dato.
Il tempo di quel bacio
diventa un tempo di eternità condivisa,
esattamente come il dito di Dio
che discende dall'Infinito
e trasforma l'Infinito in presente
e gli dà il senso e la forza
dell'essere bello qui e ora.
Lo canta il grandissimo poeta Keats
nella famosa "Ode on a Greacian Urn",
"Ode su un urna greca":
e l'urna greca è proprio questa.
Ma in che cosa consiste
quel tempo sospeso?
Io sono certo che tutti abbiate assaporato
l'essenza di quel tempo
che precede il bacio.
Perché è lì che il respiro diventa alito
e l'alito diventa anemos, vento,
e il vento diventa spirito,
e lo spirito si mescola
e si fa tiepido vapore,
e il tiepido vapore diventa emozione,
e l'emozione va condivisa,
ma va distillata piano.
Come diceva il buon Rostand,
l'ape che sugge la dolcezza del miele
dalla corolla del fiore,
ma prima ancora che questo accada,
è lì tutta la dolcezza del miele:
in un bacio non dato
che durerà nell'infinito corso del tempo,
che durerà per sempre.
E allora, Orazio, ispirandosi
ad uno stile del genere,
in una notte d'inverno,
quando il tempo sembra non finire mai,
dice alla sua bella Leuconoe
dai lunghi capelli neri,
"Scioglieteli, sciogliteli per me
adesso, in questo momento.
Lascia che i sogni ti rimangano appesi
sotto le ciglia, proprio qui sotto,
nel bordo estremo dell'occhio.
Non ti preoccupare, mai,
del tempo che Zeus ci avrebbe concesso;
non chiederti quanti inverni ancora
affaticheranno le onde
rabbiose dell'Adriatico:
questo, questo istante
che precede i nostri baci,
sia il nostro tempo per l'eternità.
Mesci generosa la coppa al vino sabino
e poi scambiamocelo
assieme ad un amore
che durando la notte intera,
potrà durare sostanzialmente per sempre".
E John Dowland, il grandissimo autore
dell'Età Elisabettiana,
in questa sua dimensione della musica
che ripete il senso di Qoelet
e della cetra ebraica,
in un'architettura musicale
che parla di vita e parla d'amore,
parla di istanti e parla di fugaci attimi,
di sensazioni e di curiose preoccupazioni,
canta, arabescando sul suo spartito,
una meraviglia, che è ancora una volta
l'incanto di una musica:
è il "Come Again! Come again! Sweet love".
"Torna ancora, torna ancora da me,
amore dolce e amore gentile.
Fa che questa mia notte
sia una notte non piena di sonno,
ma sia una notte piena di sogni.".
E che cosa siamo noi, gli fa eco
il suo forse più noto conterraneo,
se non un condensato di sogni:
un impasto di cui
è intessuta la nostra vita.
Un sogno può sembrarci
lungo quanto una vita,
lungo quanto un tempo indefinito,
e la vita può essere breve e dolce
come soltanto un sogno può essere.
È l'attesa.
È l'attesa che ci permette
di trasformare la memoria in volontà,
che ci permette di dare
un senso ed un significato
alle cose che noi assaggiamo.
L'intera Letteratura e l'intera Filosofia
giocano sul senso dell'Aspettare.
E "Aspettare" non significa
perdere il tempo,
ma significa avere l'opportunità
di assaporarlo fino in fondo.
Noi oggi non abbiamo più tempo:
corriamo in questo
"mobile ordigno di dentate rote
che macina il tempo e lo riduce in ore",
Ciro di Pers, il nostro Ciro di Pers.
Probabilmente è stato anche qui
a cantare il suo tempo.
Abbiamo paura di attendere:
le nostre sale d'attesa
sono una penosa miseria.
Abbiamo trasformato la nostra vita
nell'attendere qualche cosa
che non arriverà mai,
nel trasformare il nostro
presente in un nulla,
nell'idea che il futuro,
che ovviamente non esiste ancora,
e il passato, che non esiste più,
non acquistino significato
se non in questo debole
nostro essere qui, adesso,
che trasforma velocemente
il futuro IN passato.
Attraverso il senso della memoria
noi recuperiamo davvero chi siamo
e chi vogliamo essere
e, soprattutto, come lo vogliamo essere.
Ed è questo il lampo del Mito,
è il lampo del rito.
Nella Cueva de las Manos, nel Messico,
questo uomo del 12.000 a.C.
ha lasciato il segno del tempo
attorno al colore della sua mano:
l'ebbrezza - e ve lo consentono di fare -
di appoggiare la vostra mano
su quella mano,
vi apre una sorta di
fascinazione spazio-temporale
per cui 12.000 anni si riassumono
nel contatto di un'ombra.
L'ombra di quella mano,
che ci ricorda una cosa importante:
che noi siamo, come lui era, esseri umani,
e abbiamo bisogno di passione.
Abbiamo bisogno di sentire forte,
attraverso il Tempo,
la dimensione che è solo nostra,
perché noi lo percepiamo.
Ci sono alberi che hanno 10.000 anni -
è una cosa impressionante -
con foglie che crescono a distanza
di centinaia di anni le une dalle altre,
ma non hanno memoria di se stessi.
Io, appoggiando la mia mano
su questa mano,
ho avvertito che 12.000 anni
sono soltanto un momento,
sono soltanto un battito, un istante.
E allora ci chiediamo,
come cantava il salmista:
"Sentinella, a che punto
è arrivata la notte?".
Fino a che punto, fino a quando
noi dobbiamo attendere ed aspettare?
Impariamo ad assaporarla, la notte;
impariamo a immaginare di ascoltare,
nel buio che ci circonda,
il suono dei filamenti
dell'erba che crescono,
il ronzio che fanno le stelle
quando passano nell'alto dei cieli -
e che forse è un nostro
ronzio interiore,
lo scricchiolio dello scranno
nel quale siamo seduti.
E non stanchiamoci di chiedere mai:
"Sentinella, a che punto
è arrivata la notte?",
perché prima o poi questa verrà palesata
da un debole biancore
che compare ad Oriente
e che ci dice che forse
il tempo per noi è arrivato.
Ma attenzione, anche il mio
ormai è fuggito,
perché il tempo è questo: è il Kairos.
È rappresentato così dagli Antichi:
è un attimo fugace,
che ci rimane sempre alle spalle,
ci sorpassa quando vuole -
non ce ne rendiamo conto.
Ma ha un ciuffo, un ciuffo lungo
che gli cade sulla fronte,
e lì dobbiamo essere attenti
ad acciuffarlo, a prenderlo
nel momento in cui passa,
ad accoglierlo e a non farci
trovare impreparati.
Kairos: lo trovate sulla costa
della Dalmazia, a Trogir,
perfettamente rappresentato.
Lì, esattamente come 2.000 anni fa,
cogliere quell'istante,
cogliere quel momento,
acciuffare l'attimo,
significa pensare che la nostra vita
sia piena di tempo,
nel senso che deve mantenere
la pienezza del tempo.
Seneca: "Non sperate
di aggiungere anni alla vostra vita,
ma auspicate di aggiungere vita
ai vostri anni";
"Potrai raggiungere un'età
di ultracentenario
e non aver vissuto neanche un istante";
"Potrai vivere 30 anni, dieci anni,
un mese, un'ora soltanto,
e quel tempo sarà un tempo
intatto e meraviglioso
che ti dà il senso della meraviglia".
E allora,
come il grande Faust,
guardando l'infinità del cielo
dopo aver fatto il patto
con il nostro demonio personale -
e ciascuno di noi ha un demone
con il quale scende a patti -
arrampichiamoci sull'ultima
e più alta guglia
del pinnacolo del nostro castello
e, vedendo che il biancore
dell'alba sta arrivando
e ci dice che il nostro tempo è finito,
possiamo anche noi dirgli:
"Attimo fuggente fermati,
perché sei bello".
Grazie.
(Applausi)